Okay, so we just glimpse
this at the end last time.
This is a crystal structure of a
complicated molecule that was performed by
these same Swiss folks that we've talked
about and notice how very precise it
is.
The bond distances between atoms are
reported to plus or minus 2000th of an
angst from the bonds or are
like one and a half ox drums.
So it's like a part in a thousand is the
precision to which the positions of the
atoms is known.
Okay.
But that those positions are average
positions because the atoms are constantly
in motion vibrating. In fact, the V,
the typical vibration amplitude,
which depends on,
I've been a mom and Adam that's
off on the end of something,
is more floppy than one that's held in
by a lot of bonds in various directions
in a cage sort of thing.
But typically they're vibrating
by about 0.05 OnX drums,
which is 25 times as big as the precision
to which the position to the average
is known.
Okay.
So no molecule looks
like that at an instant.
The atoms are all displaced a little
bit. Now, how big is that here?
If you look at that yellow thing, when
it shrinks down, that's how big it is.
And that's how big the vibration is.
It's very small.
But these are very precise
measurements right? Now.
Why did they do so precise measurements?
Did they really care to know
bond distances to that accuracy?
Maybe for some purposes they did,
but that wasn't the main reason.
They did the work very carefully.
They did it carefully in order to get
really precise positions for the average
Adam,
so they could subtract spherical Adams
and see the difference accurately.
Okay?
Because if you have the wrong position
for the Adam that you're subtracting,
you get nonsense.
Okay?
And what this is going to reveal is some
pathologies of bonding from the point
of view of Louis Concept
of shared electrons. Okay?
So here's a picture of this molecule.
And remember we had the Rubo few,
Sarah in which we looked at last time,
had the great virtue that it was planer,
so you can cut a slice that
went through all the Adams.
This molecule's definitely
not playing her.
So you have to cut various
slices to see different things.
So first we'll cut a slice that
goes through those 10 atoms. Okay.
And here is the difference.
Electron density.
What does the difference density show
somebody's? Yeah, Alex.
It's the total electron
density minus the atoms.
That is how the electron density shifted
when the molecule was formed from the
atoms.
Okay?
And here we see just exactly what we
expected to see that the electrons shifted
in between the carbon atoms as the
benzene ring on the other pairs of carbon
atoms as well. It also shows the
ch bonds because in this case,
the hydrogen atoms were subtracted.
We showed one last time where the
hydrogen atoms weren't subtracted. Okay,
so this is,
there's nothing special here.
Everything looks the
way you expect it to be,
although it's really beautiful as you
would expect for these guys who do such
great work.
Now we'll do a different slice. This
is the sort of the plane of the screen,
which divides the molecule
symmetrically down the middle,
cuts through some bonds,
cuts through some atoms and so on.
So here's the difference density
map that appears on that slice.
Now the colored Adams in the right are
the positions of the atoms through which
the, the um, the plain slices,
but the atoms or subtract that out. So
what you see is the bonding in that plane.
So you'll see those bonds because both
ends of the bond are in the plains of the
bonds are in the plane and you
see just what you expect to see.
But there are other things you
see as well. You see the ch bonds,
although they don't have nearly as much
electron density is the CC bonds did,
right?
You also see that lump,
which is the unshared pair on nitrogen,
right?
But you see these two things,
which are bonds,
but there are cross sections of bonds
because this particular plane cuts through
the middle of those bonds.
Everybody see that?
Okay, so that's again, that's
nothing surprising, but here
is something surprising.
There's another bond through
which that play and cuts,
which is the one on the right through
that, through those three membered rings.
Right? And what do you
notice about that bond?
Isn't there? There isn't any
electron density for that bond.
So it's a missing bond.
This is what we're,
we'll refer to as pathological bonding,
right?
It's not what Lewis would have expected.
Maybe we don't have Louis to talk to.
So we don't know what even thought
about this particular molecule.
So here's a third plane to slice,
which goes through those three atoms
and here's the picture of it. And again,
that bond is missing that we saw before.
We're looking at,
previously we looked at
a cross section here,
we're looking at a plane that contains
the bond. And again, there's no there,
there.
Okay.
But there's something else that's
funny about this slice. You see what?
Yeah.
What's funny about the bonds that you do?
See
Corey speak up so I can
hear it. They're not,
what do you mean they're collected?
Connected separately.
I somebody say it in different words.
I think you got the idea,
but I'm not sure everybody
understood. John, do you have an idea?
Uh,
two, three, four. One, two,
three, four, five. That's true.
It is a little more dense.
That kind of thing could
be experimental error.
Because even though this
was done so precisely,
you're subtracting two
numbers that are very large,
so that any error you make
in the experimental one,
or in position in things for the
theoretical position to the Adams,
any error you make will
really be amplified in a map
like this. But it's true.
You, you noticed. But there's something I
think more interesting about those that,
yeah,
John Maybe,
yeah, they sort of overlap
one another, but of course,
if they're sort of close to another,
that doesn't surprise you too much. Uh,
because you know, as you go
out and out and out, all the,
you'll get rings that do meet
if you go far enough down. Yeah.
Crisp density on the bonds does it,
the center of density on the bonds
doesn't intersect the lines in it.
In the Adams,
the bonds are not centered on the
line that connects the nuclei.
These bonds are bent.
Okay. So again, pathological bonding,
and in three weeks you'll understand
this from first principles,
but you gotta be patient.
Yeah.
Okay.
So Louis Pairs and octets provide a pretty
good book keeping device for keeping
track of valence.
But they're hopelessly crude when it
comes to describing the actual electron
distribution,
which you can see experimentally here,
there is electron sharing.
There's a distortion of the APP,
of the spheres of,
of electron density that are the atoms,
but it's only about 5% as big as Lewis
would have predicted had he predicted
that two electrons would be right between,
okay.
And there are unshared
pairs as Louis predicted,
and again there are less than,
but in this case they're even less than
5% of what Lewis would have predicted,
but you can see them.
Now this raises the question,
is there a better bond
theory than Lewis Theory?
Maybe even one that's quantitative that
would give you numbers for these things
rather than just say their pairs
here. There. Okay. And the answer,
thank goodness is yes,
there is a great theory for this
and what it is is chemical quantum.
Now you can study quantum
mechanics in this department.
You can study quantum
mechanics and physics.
You could probably study at other places,
right?
And different people use
the same quantum mechanics,
but apply it to different problems,
right?
So what we're going to discuss in this
course is quantum mechanics as applied to
bonding.
Okay.
So it will be somewhat
different in its flavor of fact,
a lot different in its flavor from what
you do in physics or even what you do in
physical chemistry because
we're more interested.
We're not so interested in getting
numbers or solving mathematical problems.
We're interested in getting insight to
what's really involved in forming bonds.
We want it to be rigorous,
but we don't need it to be numerical.
Okay. So it'll be much more
pictorial than numerical. Okay.
So it came with the Schrodinger's
wave equation that was,
that was discovered in our invented,
perhaps we should say in 90 I dunno
whether it's hard to know whether to say
discovered or invented,
I think invented is probably better
in 1926 and here is shredding or the
previous year that sort of 97
pound weakling on the beach. Right?
He's this guy back here
with the glasses on. Okay.
He was actually a well known physicist,
but he hadn't done anything
really earth shaking at all.
He was at the University of Zurich
and Felix Bloch,
who was a student then the previous two,
two years before he had
come as an undergraduate to
the University of Zurich to
study engineering. And after a year and
a half, he decided he would do physics,
which was completely impractical and not
to the taste of his parents. But anyhow,
as an undergraduate he went to
these Colloquia, the that the, uh,
physics department had and
he wrote 50 years later,
so this was 1976.
So it's the 50th anniversary
of the discovery of,
or invention of quantum mechanics. So he
said at the end of a co of a colloquium,
I heard Dubai, there's a picture
of Dubai. Say something like,
Schrodinger you're not working right
now on very important problems anyway.
Why don't you tell us something
about that thesis of debris oily.
So in one of the next colloque we assured
that your gave a beautifully clear
account of how to Broil.
He associated a wave with a particle.
When he had finished Dubai,
casually remarked that he thought this
way of talking was rather childish.
He had learned that to deal properly with
waves, one had to have a wave equation.
It sounded rather trivial and did
not seem to make a great impression,
but Schrodinger evidently thought a bit
more about the idea afterwards and just
a few weeks later he gave
another talk in the colloquium,
which he started by saying,
my colleague Dubai suggested that
one should have a wave equation.
Well, I have found, and we write it now,
each side equals east side. He actually
wrote it in different terms, but,
but that's the Schrodinger equation.
The reason when we ride is
a little different from his
is he included time as a
variable in his,
whereas we're not interested in for
this purpose in changes in time.
We want to see how molecules are
when they're just sitting there.
We'll talk about time later.
So within a what,
seven years,
here's shredding or looking
a good deal sharper. Right.
And where is he standing?
He's standing at the,
at the tram stop in Stockholm where he's
going to pick up his Nobel prize for
this. Right. And he's standing
with Dubai with a Dereck,
with whom he shared the Nobel prize and
with Heisenberg who got the Nobel prize
the previous year, but hadn't collected
it yet, so he came at the same time.
Okay, sure. The Schrodinger
equation is HCI equals east side,
H and e you've seen, but side may
be due to you. It's a Greek letter.
We can call it PSI or PSI.
Some people call it c,
right? I'll, I'll probably call it
side. Okay. And it's a wave function.
But what in the world is a wave function?
Okay.
So this,
this is a stumbling block for people that
come into the field and it's not just
a stumbling block for you.
It was a stumbling block for the
greatest minds there were at the time.
So for example,
this is five years later in Leipzig
and it's the research group of Verner
Heisenberg. You're sitting there
in the front, the guy that,
this was about the time he was being
nominated or selected for the Nobel Prize,
right?
So He's there with his research group
and right behind him is seated Felix
Bloch,
who himself got the Nobel prize
for discovering Nmr in 1952.
So he's quite a young guy here
and he's with these other, uh,
there's a guy who became famous at Oxford
and another one who became the head of
the physics department at
Mit Block was at Stanford.
So these guys know
they're pretty hot stuff.
So they're looking right into the camera,
right to record themselves for posterity
as part of this distinguished group,
except for block.
What's he thinking about?
What in the world is PSI right
now? In fact, in that saved me,
or it was in January that Schrodinger
announced the wave equation and sy and
that summer that these smart guys who,
uh,
who were hanging around Zurich at
that time, theoretical physicists,
the young guys went out on an excursion
on the lake of Zurich and they,
uh,
they made up dog roll rhymes for fun
about different things that were going on.
And the one that, that, uh, was
made up by block, an aerial vehicle
who we'll talk about next semester,
was about sy Garmin,
just rational urban Sean met Ziner of
Ellen Fonsi on nor vison Mcmahon Garren
avoid [inaudible] for stones all,
which means Aaron,
with his PSI can do calculations.
Quite a few.
We only wish that we could glean
an inkling of what cy could mean,
right? Yup. You can do
calculations with it,
but what is it was the question.
Okay.
And it wasn't just these
young guys who were confused,
even shrugger was never comfortable
with what side really means.
Now, if we're lucky, this'll play this
time. So this is a lecture by Schrodinger.
What is matter from 1952
I am on
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible],
right?
So what is six years later?
Schrodinger still didn't
really know what PSI was. Okay.
So don't be depressed when it seems
a little curious what cy might be,
right? First we'll like shredding
or unlike these other guys.
First we'll learn how
to find sy and use it,
and then later we'll learn what it means.
So Cy is a function, a wave
function. What do you want to know
from what I've shown here?
What is a function?
Relationship
like sign as a function.
What does that mean?
Yeah. Yeah. I can't hear very well.
[inaudible]
yeah, it's, it's like a little machine.
You put a number in or maybe several
numbers and the number comes out,
right? That's what the function does
that you put in 90 degrees in size.
So sign says one.
Okay.
So what do you want to
know about the PSI first?
Yes.
What's the function of what?
What are the things you have to put
in in order to get a number out?
Okay, so it's different
from the name the, this,
the way functions have names,
that's not what they're a function of,
right? You can have sign
sine squared, coast side,
those are different functions, but they
can be functions of the same thing.
An angle, right? So we're
interested in what's that?
A function of not what the function is,
but what's that a function of.
So you can have different size,
they have names for and quantum
numbers give them their names.
For example,
you can have an l and M,
you've seen those before and
LM to name wave functions.
Those are just their names.
That's not what they're a function of.
Or you can have one s or three d,
x, y or sigma or Pi or Pi Star.
Those are all names of functions,
right? But they're not what?
It's a function of
what is a function of is the position
of a particle or a set of particles.
It's a function of position and
it's also a function of time.
And sometimes have spin part at some
particles have spin and it could be a
function of that too.
But you'll be happy to know that
for purposes of this course,
we're not so interested in time and spin.
So for our purposes,
it's just a function of position.
So if you have in particles,
how many positions do you have to
specify to know where they all are?
How many numbers do you need? You
need x, Y, Z for every particle,
right?
So you need three in arguments for Sai.
So Sai is a function that when you
tell it where all these positions are,
it gives you a number.
Now, curiously enough,
the number can be positive. It
can be zero, it could be negative,
it can even be complex,
right?
Although we won't talk about
cases where it's complex.
The physicist will tell you
about those or physical chemists.
Okay. And sometimes it can be as
many as four n plus one arguments.
How could it be for n plus one?
Cause if each particle also had
a spin than it would be x, Y,
Z and spin that it'd be four. And if
time is also included, it's plus one.
Okay. So how are we going to go
through this first? We'll try.
This is unfamiliar territory, I
bet to every one of you. Okay.
So first we're going to talk about
just one part nickel and one dimension.
So the function is fairly simple,
okay?
And then we'll go on to three dimensions,
but still one particle,
the in an atom. So a one electron
atom, but now three dimensions.
So it's more complicated.
Then we'll go on to atoms
that have several electrons.
So you have now more than three
variables because you have at least two
electrons.
That would be six variables that you
have to put into the function to get a
number out.
Then we'll go into molecules that is
more than one atom and what bonding is.
And then finally we get to the
payoff for organic chemistry,
which is talking about what makes a group
of functional group and what does it
mean to be functional, what makes it
reactive? That's where we're heading.
But first we have to understand
what quantum mechanics is.
So here's the Schrodinger equation,
h cycles east side,
and we're talking about the time
independent Schrodinger equation.
So time is not a variable.
Uh,
and that means it's what we're
talking about is stationary states.
It's that we don't mean that
the atoms aren't moving,
but just that they're in a cloud.
And we were going to find that
how has the cloud distributed?
If a molecule reacts, the electrons
shift to their clouds and so on.
The it changes.
We're not interested in reaction.
Now we're just interested in
understanding the cloud at sitting there,
not changing in time. Okay. Now,
the right part of the equation
is e times PSI, right?
And he will turn out to be
the energy of the system.
Maybe you won't be surprised that that,
so that's quite simple. What's the left?
It looks like h times psi.
If that were true,
what could you do to simplify things?
Knock outside.
But h time HCI is not h times Psi h is
sort of a recipe for doing something with
Sy. We'll see that right away. So
you can't just cancel out the PSI,
unfortunately. Okay, so
HCI equals Esi. Oops,
sorry. What did I do? There
we go. Now we can divide.
You can divide the right by cy.
And since it was eat time side,
the side goes away.
But what you divide on the left,
you don't cancel the size because
the top doesn't mean multiplication.
No, I already told you the right side
of this equation is the total energy.
So when you see a sister,
what does the total energy consist of?
Potential energy and kinetic energy.
So somehow this part on the left h over
sy must be kinetic energy plus potential
energy.
That recipe h must somehow tell you
how to work with PSI in order to get
something which divided by sy Gibbs,
kinetic energy plus potential energy.
So there are two parts of it.
There's the part that's potential energy
of the recipe and there's part that's
kinetic energy.
Now
the potential energy part is in
fact easy because it's given to you,
right? What's, what's the,
what's Sigh? A function of
position of the particles.
Now if you know of the charges of the
particles and their positions and no cool
ohms law, then you know the potential
energy if cool ohms law is right.
Is everybody with me on that? If you
know there's a unit positive charge here,
a unit negative charge here,
another unit, positive charge here,
and a unit negative charge here,
something like that you,
it's might be complicated,
you might have to write an excel
program or something to do it,
but you could calculate the distances
and the charges and so on and what the
energy is due to that.
So that part is really given to you
once you know what system you're dealing
with, the recipe for finding,
finding the potential energy.
So that part of HCI oversight
is no problem at all.
But hold your breath on kinetic energy.
Sam,
let me just throw a face.
There was like an adjusted,
yeah, that was wrong. That
was three years earlier.
Remember 1923 Thompson proposed that,
but it was,
it was wrong.
This is what was right.
How did what just,
yeah, they, they prove this right.
And the cool ohms law held because it
agreed with a whole lot of spectroscopic
evidence that had been
collected about atomic spectrum.
And then everything else has tried with
it works too. So we believe it now.
So how do you handle kinetic
energy? Well, that's an old one.
You did that already in high school,
right? Forget kinetic energy. Here it is.
It's some constant which will
get you the units, right?
Depending on what energy units you want
times the sum over all the particles of
the kinetic energy of each particle.
So you know,
if you know the kinetic energy
of this particle, Kinetic Energy,
this particle is part of this particle.
You add them all up,
you get the total kinetic energy,
no problem there right now.
What is the kinetic energy that
you're summing up over each particle?
It's one half MV squared, if any.
Has everybody seen that before?
Okay?
Okay,
so that's the sum of classical kinetic
energy over all the particles of interest
in the problem and the constant is just
some number you put in to get the right
units for your energy depending on whether
you use feet per second or meters per
year or whatever for the velocity.
Okay?
But it turned out that all of this,
although this was fine for
our great grandparents,
it's not right when you start
dealing with tiny things. All right,
here's what kinetic energy really is.
It's a constant, this is the thing
that gets it in the right units.
H squared over eight Pi squared
times a sum over all the particles.
It's looking promising right
of one over the mass,
not the mass MV squared,
but one over the mass of each particle.
And here's where we get it.
Times second derivatives
of a wave function.
That's weird.
I mean at least it has tools
in it like v squared, right?
That's something. And in fact it's not
completely coincidental that it has to,
is in it.
There was an analogy that
was being followed that
allowed them to formulate this
and you divide it by the numbers Psi.
So that's a pretty complicated thing.
So if we want to get our heads around
it, we better simplify it. And Oh,
also there's a minus sign.
It's minus the constant is
negative that you use. Okay?
Now let's simplify it by
using just one particle.
So we don't have to some over a bunch
of particles and we'll use just one
dimension x, forget y and Z. Okay,
so now we see something
similar set simpler.
So it's a negative constant times one
over the mass of the particle times the
second derivative of the function,
the wave function divided by sy.
That's kinetic energy. Really
not what happened. V squared.
Okay. Or here it is written
just a little differently.
So there's a constant seat over the mass,
right?
And then we have the important
part is the second derivative.
Does everybody know that the second
derivative is a curvature of a function,
right?
What's the first derivative slope and the
second derivative is how curved it is.
It could be curving down.
That's negative curvature or curving up.
That's positive curvature,
so it can be positive.
It can be zero if the line is straight.
Okay,
so note that the kinetic energy
involves the Sheaf of sy,
how curved it is,
not just what the value of cy is,
although it involves that too.
Yeah,
maybe it's not too early to point
out something interesting about this.
That's so I suppose that's
the kinetic energy, right?
What would happen if you
multiplied sy by two?
Obviously you'd denominator,
we get twice as large.
If you made side twice as large,
what would happen to the
curvature if what happens to the,
suppose you have a function and you make
it twice as big and look at the slope
at a particular point.
How does a slope change?
If you've stretched the paper on which
you drew it it the slope will double,
right? If you double the
scale, how about the curvature?
The second derivative
is to go up by four times.
No, it doesn't go up by four
times. It goes up by twice.
So what happened? Well, what would
happen to the kinetic energy there?
If we doubled the size of sy every place,
it would stay the same. The kinetic energy
doesn't depend on how you scale PSI.
It only depends on its shape,
how curved it is.
Everybody see the idea
curvature divided by the value.
Okay?
Now solving a quantum problem.
So if you're in a course you have and
you're studying quantum mechanics,
you've got problems to solve
now.
So you're, what are you, you a
problem means you're given something.
You have to find something. You're
given a set of particles, right?
Like a certain nuclei,
nuclei have given mass and charge and
elect a certain number of electrons.
That's what you're given.
Okay?
The masses of the particles
and the potential law.
When you're given the charge
and you know cool ohms law,
then you know how to calculate
the potential energy.
Remember, that's part of it.
Okay? But that part, so
that part's easy. Okay.
Now what do you need to find if
you have a problem to solve? Oh,
for example, you can have one
particle in one dimension,
so it could be one atomic mass unit is
the way that the particle and Hooke's law
could be the potential, right?
It doesn't have to be realistic.
Could be Hooke's law could be a
particle held by a spring, right?
To find his cy.
You want to find the
shape of this function,
which is a function of what
positions of the particles,
and if you're higher the further
on than we are time as well.
Maybe spin even,
but that function has to be such that
HCI oversight is the total energy and the
total energy is the same no
matter where the particle is,
right? Because the potential energy
in the kinetic energy cancel out.
It's like a ball rolling back and forth.
The total energy is constant,
but it goes back and forth between
potential and kinetic energy, right?
Same thing here.
No matter where the particles are,
you have to get the same energy.
So Cy has to be such that
when you calculate the
kinetic energy for it changes
in that kinetic energy in
different positions. Exactly.
Compensate for the changes
in potential energy.
When you've got that,
then you've got a correct side.
Maybe
it's also important that cy,
Romaine finite,
that it not go to infinity,
and if you're a real mathematician,
it has to be single valued. You can't
have two values for the same positions.
It has to be continuous.
You can't get a sudden break
inside and size square.
It has to be integratable,
right? You have to find out how.
You have to be able to tell how much
area is undersized squared and you'll see
why shortly.
But basically what you need is to find
a size such that the changes in kinetic
energy compensate changes
in potential energy.
Now, what's coming, this
is rehearsal we did before.
So first there'll be one
particle in one dimension,
then it'll be one electron atoms.
So one particle in three dimensions.
Then it will be many electrons
and the idea of what orbitals are,
and then there'll be molecules of
bonds and finally functional groups and
reactivity.
Okay.
But you will be happy to hear
that by a week from Friday.
We'll only get through one electron atoms.
So don't worry about the
rest of the stuff now,
but do read the parts on the webpage that
have to do with what's going to be on
the exam. Okay? So normally
you're given a problem,
the mass and the charges.
That is the potential energy
as a function of position.
And you need to find sigh.
But at first we're going
to try it a different way.
We're going to play jeopardy and we're
gonna start with the answer and find out
what the question was.
Okay?
So suppose that sy is the sine of x.
This is one particle in one dimension.
The position of the particle and
the function is of Cy is sign.
If you know cy, what can you figure
out? We'd just been talking about it.
What can you use AI to find
kinetic energy? How do you find it?
So we can get the kinetic energy,
which is minus a constant over the
mass times the curvature aside to valid
divided by cy at any given position.
Right?
And once we know how the kinetic
energy varies with position,
then we know how the potential energy
varies with position because it's just the
opposite in order that the
sum be constant, right?
So once we know the kinetic energy, then
we know what the potential energy was,
which was what the problem
was at the beginning. Okay,
so suppose our answer is sine of x.
Uh,
what is the curvature of sine of x?
The second derivative?
It's minus the sine of X.
Okay.
So what is the Connecticut or g
c over m? Does it depend on
where you are on the value of x?
No, it's always see over him. So
what was the potential energy?
How did the potential
energy very with position,
the potential energy
doesn't vary with position.
So sine of x is a solution for what?
A particle,
it's not being influenced by anything
else. So it's energy, it's potential.
Energy doesn't change with a position.
It's a particle and free space.
Okay,
so it's independent that
potential energy independent of x,
constant potential energy.
It's a particle and free space.
Now suppose we take a
different one sign of aix.
How does sign of aix look
different from sine of x?
Suppose it sine of two x Zillow here,
here's sine of x.
How does sine of two x look
great,
right?
It's a shorter wavelength.
Okay. Now, uh,
so we need to figure out, so it's a
shortened way of if a is greater than one.
Okay. Now, what's the curvature,
Russell?
It's a squared times sine of x of Aix,
right?
The a comes out that constant
each time you take a derivative.
So now what does the potential,
the kinetic energy look like?
It's a squared times the same thing.
Okay?
So again, it's a, the potential
energy is constant, right?
Does it change with position?
But what is different?
It has higher kinetic energy
if it's a shorter wavelength.
And notice that the kinetic energy is
proportional to one over the wavelength
squared, right? A squared,
a shortens the wave,
right?
It's proportional days square one
over the wavelength squared. Okay?
Now let's take another function
exponential. So e to the x,
okay,
what's the second derivative
of e to the x? Arden?
Me either the x,
what's the 18th derivative of e to the x?
Okay, good. So it's either the
x. So what's this situation?
What's the kinetic energy
minus c over em?
Negative kinetic energy.
Your great grandparents didn't get that.
You can have kinetic energy
that's less than zero.
What does that mean?
It means the total energy is
lower than the potential energy.
Pause a minute just to let that sink in.
The total energy is lower
than the potential energy.
The differences. Negative.
Okay,
so the kinetic energy,
if that's the difference between
potential and total is negative.
You never get that for
one half MV squared. Yes,
violate what
you'll see in a second. Okay, so anyhow,
the constant potential energy is greater
than the total energy for that. Now,
how about if it were minus exponential
e to the minus x now what would that be?
It would be the same deal. Again, it
would still be minus c over m and again,
it would be a constant potential
energy greater than the total energy.
This is not just a mathematical curiosity.
It actually happens for
every atom in you or in me.
Every atom has the electrons spend some
of their time in regions where they have
negative kinetic energy.
It's not just something weird
that would never happens.
And it happens at large distance
from the Nuclei where one over R,
that's the cool ohms law where
it stops changing very much,
right?
When you get far enough,
one over r gets really tiny
and it's essentially zero.
It doesn't change anymore,
right?
Then you have the
situation in any real Adam.
So, uh, let's look at, uh,
getting the potential energy from the
shape of sy via the kinetic energy.
Okay? So here's a map of PSI or a plot
of cy could be positive, negative,
zero as a function of the one dimension
x, wherever the particle is, okay?
Now let's suppose that
that is our wave function.
Sometimes positive, sometimes
zero, sometimes negative, okay?
And let's look at different positions
and see what the kinetic energy is and
then we'll be able to figure out,
since the total will be constant,
what the potential energy is.
Okay?
So we'll try to find out
what was potential energy
that gave this as a solution.
This is again, the
jeopardy approach. Okay,
so the curvature of minus,
remember it's a negative constant minus
the curvature over the amplitude could
be positive. That's going to be the
kinetic energy. Could be positive,
could be zero,
could be negative,
or it could be that we can't
tell by looking at the graph.
So let's look at different positions on
the graph and see what it says first.
Look at that position. What is the
kinetic energy there? Positive,
negative zero.
Ryan, why don't you help me out?
Well, no, you can help me out. Look,
so what do you need to know?
You need to know. You need,
here's the complicated thing. You
have to figure out. What is the,
is is minus the curvature divided
by the amplitude at this point?
Is it positive, negative, or zero? So
what's the curvature at that point?
Is it curving up or down at that point?
No idea. Anybody got an idea, Kevin?
It's not a settled point.
What do you call it?
Sample points three for three
dimensions in. In this. It's what?
Inflection point. It's flat there.
It's curving one way on one side,
the other way on the other side. So it's
got zero curvature there. Zero curvature.
Now Ryan, can you tell me anything about
that? Cause the curvature. Zero. Zero,
[inaudible]
not bad.
So that one will color gray for zero.
The kinetic energy at that point is zero.
If that's the way function.
Now let's take another point.
Who's going to help me with this one?
How about the curvature
at this point right here?
It's actually I chose a
point that's not curved.
It straight right there.
I assure you. That's true.
So I've met Ryan can help me
again on that one. How about it?
So we'll make that one gray too. Now
I'll go to someone else. How about there?
What's the curvature at that point?
Do you think Shai,
it looks straight. Zero curvature. So
does that mean the trust value is zero?
Ah,
the amplitude is zero there too.
So really you can't be sure,
right?
So that when we're going to have to leave
questionable. That's a question mark.
How about out here?
Not Curved.
So what's the kinetic energy,
Josh?
Questionable. Right? Because
amplitude is zero. Again, your device,
the zero in the numerator, also zero in
the denominator. We really don't know.
Okay.
How about here,
Tyler? What do you say? Is it curved?
They're curving up or
down? Yeah. So negative.
The curvatures negative.
The value of sy. Positive.
The energy. Kinetic
energy. Positive. Okay,
so we can make that when green.
Okay. Here's another one.
Who's going to help me here.
Okay.
Okay. So how about the curvature?
Curving up. Curving down?
Yeah. Amplitude. Ah, green again.
Okay. Uh, how about here? Ah, no.
Now about the curvature.
Seth,
which way is it curbing at
this point here? Curving up.
So the curvature is positive.
Yeah.
So what color we make it green again.
Okay.
So if you're,
you could have be curving down or curving
up and still be positive curving down.
If you're above the baseline, curving
up. If you're below the baseline. Right?
So as long as you're curving toward
the baseline towards cycle equal zero,
the energy is pop. Kinetic energy
is positive. How about here,
Zach?
Which way is it? Curving,
curving up or curving down?
It should be curving out. Serving
up curvature is positive. The value,
positive, positive, I guess
will be negative. So negative,
kinetic energy there.
Make that one whenever that
pinkish color is. Okay,
here's another one.
How about there
Alex?
Which way is it curving
at the new place here,
curving down negative curvature.
Negative amplitude,
negative, negative. Kinetic energy.
Pink. Again, is that enough?
Hope.
There's one more here.
The one right here.
Okay.
Pardon? Negative cause. It's how
can you, how did you do it so quick?
We didn't have to go through curvature
cause it's curving away from the baseline.
Negative. Okay. Uh, paint. Okay.
Curving away from cy equals zero means
that the kinetic energy is negative.
So now we know what all these positions,
whether the kinetic energy is positive,
negative or zero, although are a few that
we don't aren't certain about, right?
So here's the potential
energy that will do that.
If you have this line for
the total energy, right?
Then here and here you have zero,
right? Also, incidentally,
here and here you have zero
kinetic energy with me,
okay? So No curvature, right?
At these green places,
the total energy is higher
than the potential energy.
So the kinetic energy is positive,
okay?
At these places, the potential energy
is higher than the total energy.
So the kinetic energy is negative and
the thing is curving away from the
baseline.
All right?
And now we know something
about this point. If the,
if the potential energy is
continuous kind of thing,
then although we couldn't tell
by looking at the wave function,
it's curving away from the
baseline, but very slightly, right?
It's negative, kinetic
energy there. And also, uh,
on the right here is
negative kinetic energy.
And here we know that just by continuity,
that at this point it must have
been positive kinetic energy,
even though we couldn't tell
it by looking at the curve,
there must be an inflection
point when you go through zero,
otherwise you get a discontinuity in
the, in the, uh, potential energy.
Okay? So that one was green. Okay,
now I have to stop.